this is another gem this one here we go
Rolling Stone a furry fandom Con in
Florida just announced it would ban
miners based on the governor's
ridiculous laws Connor leave this up for
just a moment because we have to unpack
what's going on here so first off you go
you're watching the Reuben report you're
good family people you don't know what a
furry fandom kind is Brock what's a
furry fandom con
we should go it is look there's a
certain set of people who who am I to
judge they dress up as these furry
animals that I don't know they hang out
they have coffee I guess they maybe have
sex or whatever they're doing with each
other that's fine they've canceled their
convention by the way nobody had a
problem with their convention I think
better O'Rourke is one of these people
nobody had a problem with these people
that dress up as plush animals and hang
out with other people dressed as plush
animals and you do it in the privacy of
your own home or in a convention
somewhere but you don't do it in front
of children because the joking aside
there actually is a sexual element to it
okay that they have sex as oh you're
you're a Charmander and I'm
something else
God can you imagine how stupid
everything's gonna be in 10 years I have
to retire that's it I'm getting out of
the grind who needs it
um but all Florida did was say you can't
bring children to your furry sex party
so now but put it up again because the
way Rolling Stone frames it it makes it
seem like Florida's doing the wrong
thing a furry fandom Con in Florida just
announced it would ban miners based on
the governor's ridiculous laws all the
governor said was don't bring kids when
you put on a dragon costume and bang
some dude from out of state
[Music]
oh